[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a shocking revelation in the murder
murder mystery are you innocent of every
ministry
if i just shot him it did
he's alive this just hours before alec
murdoch is arrested for the second time
and the federal trial of elizabeth
holmes how prominent reporters are
fighting back to maintain their coverage
of the case plus we're just days away
from jury selection in the trial of
ahmad aubrey's murder
we take a look back at the case so far
and later a shocking connection in the
disappearance of kathy durst it's bob i
jumped up
i ran out the ex-husband of first lady
jill biden says he once had an affair
with robert durst's first wife law on
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin another set of twists and turns
in the murdoch murder mystery out of
south carolina an alleged suicide for
hire hitman says alec murdoch was never
shot in the head all this just hours
before murdoch is arrested for the
second time
murdoch was taken into custody on
thursday on two counts of obtaining
property by false pretenses the charges
stem from misappropriated settlement
funds in the death of murdoch family
housekeeper gloria statterfield
satterfield died mysteriously on the
family property in 2018. an autopsy was
never performed the south carolina law
enforcement division says murdoch was
taken into custody upon his release from
an orlando drug rehab center he is being
held at the orange county corrections
department until he is extradited to his
home state of south carolina murdoch a
once prominent attorney has led
investigators along a string of
mysterious deaths and incidents over the
past year in june murdoch's wife and son
were found murdered on family property
murdoch has been since named a person of
interest in that case three months after
their deaths murdoch reported he was
shot in the head while changing a flat
tire mourdock later revealed he had an
opioid drug addiction and had hired 61
year old curtis eddie smith to shoot and
kill him murdoch claimed he staged the
failed suicide by a higher scheme so his
remaining son could benefit from a life
insurance policy in an exclusive
interview with the today's show smith
claims murdoch set him up and that
murdoch himself was never shot in the
head
he's standing like this he said you're
gonna shoot me i said no he said he just
got do it he made his move like like
this you know
and i just grabbed his arm
you took the gun
and shoved up behind him
between me and him
and went up
the gun went off did it hit him did the
bullet hit him no
so that i that that story where he got
good on me there's no blood on him he
didn't get shot in the head no did your
client ever sell drugs to alec murdoch
no absolutely not everybody's met my
client now you just saw him on tv i've
never had a client in 13 years
representing people break down and cry
after some sort of issue like this and
you mentioned the insurance scheme but
mr murdoch's attorneys yesterday
yesterday came out and said no no mr
smith didn't know about the insurance
scheme beforehand no no he just showed
up and obliged to shoot him
so apparently the conspiracy to commit
insurance fraud should be dismissed
today
joining us today is civil rights
attorney katie smith and terry austin
katie so now the hitman was set up do
you believe him and what could this mean
for murdoch
it's really tough brian because this was
a very detailed account of a very
convoluted incident and with things like
this we always want to look to the
forensics the forensics will be able to
tell conclusory whether or not he's
telling the truth and the risk with
coming out publicly like this is you
can't walk it back he's already made his
case to the public and that's going to
be binding
all right terry with all of these
arrests and now an extradition back to
south carolina what do you think the
penalties will look like for murdoch for
his legal license his liberty and his
life
you know murdoch could face years if not
life in prison we already know it's a
huge fall from grace he was a respected
attorney his family had a good
reputation but now he's facing charges
for misappropriation of these settlement
funds he's facing charges for insurance
fraud conspiracy to commit suicide and
don't forget obviously the fact that his
wife and son have been killed and if he
is indicted and faces charges for that
he could spend the rest of his life in
prison you know a lot of twists and
turns that we said in this murder
mystery and we'll take you down each
turn as we see them thank you both in
other top legal news the fbi returns to
the swamp area near northport florida in
the search for brian laundry
laundry was the fiance of gabby potito
who went missing in august potato's
remains were found in wyoming last month
the coroner says she was strangled to
death laundry has been missing from his
parents home in florida since at least
september 13th
the 24 000 acre reserve has been
searched a number of times for laundry a
human remains detection dog is searching
the area to detect the presence of a
body or the lack of one in the swamp
laundry faces a federal charge related
to the misuse of petito's debit card and
has been named a person of interest in
her death
and just months after his release from
prison comedian bill cosby is served
with another lawsuit lily bernard says
cosby drugged and raped her in august of
1990. according to the lawsuit cosby
courts bernard to travel from new york
city to atlantic city where the alleged
rape happened the lawsuit says cosby
became a mentor to bernard and an
aspiring actress even offering to
feature her on the cosby show in july
cosby was released from prison when
pennsylvania's supreme court overturned
his criminal sexual assault case the 84
year old served more than two years of
his sentence
still ahead on law and crime daily
looking ahead to jury selection in the
trial of ahmad armory's murder but first
reporters fighting to cover the case in
the federal trial of elizabeth holmes we
break down the motions two prominent
journalists filed in relation to the
case all that and more after the break
[Music]
it was the video that shocked the nation
an unarmed black jogger 25 year old
ahmad abre gunned down in broad daylight
the three men charged will now stand
trial for live galvado gabo coverage of
the trial subscribe to law and crime on
youtube tv today
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily as
the federal trial of elizabeth holmes
stretches into week six prominent
journalists file a motion of their own
in regards to covering the trial
as we've reported on law and crime daily
pulitzer prize-winning reporter john
kehru filed a motion to be exempt from
witness exclusion after holmes defense
team added him to the witness list
in 2015 kairu broke the theranos fraud
story that would be the catalyst for
holmes charges earlier this month kerry
roo's attorney said adding the reporter
to holmes witness list was just a ruse
so that he could not cover the trial on
thursday cariru addressed the court
asking to keep in mind his first
amendment rights as a journalist seeing
an exclusion order meaning a witness
cannot be in the courtroom for other
witness testimony or gag order meaning a
witness cannot discuss their testimony
should not apply to kerry roo fellow
reporter roger parloff filed a similar
motion in an effort to maintain
confidentiality in his reporter notes
and recordings holmes the former ceo of
theranos claimed the company would
revolutionize blood testing she now
faces 12 fraud charges in federal court
back to break down the latest in the
theron's trial is civil rights attorney
katie smith and terry austin terry
what's kerryroo's strongest argument and
is it a winning one
well i think his strongest argument is
the first amendment and i do think it's
a winning one
freedom of the speech and freedom of the
press are the two major arguments in the
first amendment and fremo the press
really means he has the right to gather
information he has the right to
disseminate that information and he has
the right to keep that information
confidential now courts have in the past
made journalists disclose information
and they can subject them to fines and
penalties you might recall judith miller
for the new york times she was actually
held in jail because she refused to
disclose her source here though i don't
think there's any sort of security
interest or compelling argument that the
court would win so i do think that he's
going to win a first amendment argument
i think he will defeat that gag order
and i think that he'll be able to go
into the court and be able to listen to
the other witnesses at the end of the
day now katie winning an argument is
half the battle how do you think the
judge will apply it do you think the
judge will split the baby so to speak
and i have both reporters there for some
of the testimony but not all or do you
think it's all or nothing from here
brian i'm usually a big fan of split the
baby but there's some things you can't
negotiate that way and being a witness
and then sitting in for others witness
testimony is problematic i think what
the judge should first do is a showing
to see whether or not he would actually
be a fact witness and then if there's
some evidentiary finding then maybe
preclude him from sitting in but if
there's no reason and it is all a ruse
then absolutely i believe i totally
agree with terry he should be there yeah
i think the fact-based hearing would be
the interesting part uh
i i think it's pretty petty of the
defense attorneys i'm just going to
throw it out there i think it's a bit of
a ruse i don't see a reason for him to
testify and what's the harm from having
him report the case i would love to see
a fact based hearing here and see how
that plays out i think that's definitely
the move here thank you both a lot of
podcasts focus on true crime stories now
there's a new podcast that looks
specifically at the forensics of those
cases angela levy spoke with joseph
scott morgan about his new podcast body
bags
for 20 years joseph scott morgan worked
as a forensic death investigator he also
teaches about forensics at jacksonville
state university and now he's taking his
expertise into the world of podcasting
he has a new podcast out it's called
body bags joseph thanks so much for
joining us at what prompted you to do
this podcast i felt as though that
there's
a grand void
in the podcast world relative to
forensics and
yes i have been a death investigator and
a forensic scientist but
you know i've spent
the better part of two decades now as an
educator there's such a diminishment of
information and kind of how you kind of
drill down into what the facts are as
opposed to
you know
a lot of the drama that surrounds things
you know let's talk about science
because the sciences is equally
compelling and exciting i listened to
the first episode and it really takes a
deep dive into the forensics and in that
first episode you talk about the gabby
potito case and really
apply your expertise to explain to the
listeners what's going on you're
learning within the morgue
to kind of read what the dead are
leaving behind i know that's horribly
cliche but you know we always say you
know we speak for those that can no
longer speak for themselves and it's the
science it's not us speaking but it's us
interpreting the science that's left
behind by the dead and the life that was
lived
and so i think that that's that's
something that people want to know about
the gabby gabby potito case is
is a fine example
because
uh we don't have any information
i mean we really don't i mean other than
the fact you know
that
the
most glaring thing is that
those forensic scientists the coroner
the forensic pathologist they shot out
of that door on that tuesday afternoon
and they proclaimed that the manner of
death was specifically a homicide well
it's a really interesting podcast and
i'm sure our viewers and listeners
will enjoy it too so joseph scott morgan
thanks for joining us today to talk
about body bags and we'll send it back
to you in the studio
thanks ange as a friend and colleague of
jsm and a homicide public defender who
learned so much just i'm hearing them
speak i can't say enough definitely
check out body bags and coming up on law
and crime daily a startling connection
to the disappearance of kathy durst how
first lady joe biden's passed
intertwines with the unsolved murder
plus examining events leading up to the
trial of ahmad arbore's accused murders
we break down the case so far after the
break
[Music]
welcome back as we look ahead to next
week's trial for the death of a mod
arbory we're taking a closer look into
the charges against now former district
attorney jackie johnson
johnson was the top prosecutor in glenn
county georgia at the time of the
shooting she previously worked directly
with the defendant gregory mcmichaels
while he was an investigator for the
brunswick judicial circuit district
attorney's office though the incident
happened in late february 2020 no
arrests were made until may when the
video of the shooting was leaked on the
day of the shooting johnson is accused
of preventing two police officers from
exercising their duties according to the
indictment johnson violated her oath by
quote showing favor and affection to
gregory mcmichael during the
investigation jones was voted out of her
role in november 2020 and was later
charged in september 2021 with
obstructing a police officer and
violating her oath of office she faces a
felony charge for violating her oath of
office that carries a one to five year
prison sentence whereas the charge for
obstructing a police officer carries up
to 12 months on the day of the shooting
gregory mcmichaels called johnson and
left this
voicemail jackie this is great can you
call me as soon as you possibly can um
and i need some advice right away please
call me
here to break down jackie johnson's
involvement in the death of a mod aubry
is civil rights attorney katie smith and
co-host terry austin terry consciousness
of guilt is a huge part of cases as as
you know does calling a head prosecutor
after a shooting show grabbing michael
believe he may have been in hot water
even if he thought he was doing a
citizen's arrest
you know there's no question about it
brian it is consciousness of guilt here
as far as mcmichael is concerned first
of all the prosecutor is his former boss
and he's the defendant and he should not
be calling the prosecutor for advice so
clearly he should go through his
attorney and that's just a minor point
the bigger point is was he trying to
influence or obstruct justice here was
he trying to in any way shape the
investigation and i think an argument
can be made that he was trying to do
exactly that which is why he made that
phone call and he left the message on
the recording so i think it shows real
consciousness of guilt and i think if
that comes in that the jury's going to
believe the same exact thing now katie
if someone was defending this case i can
see the argument be that the pastor's
attorneys decided not to prosecute the
mcmichaels and this arguably is a
political prosecution but with one of
the former da's being prosecuted does
that change things
you know brian it really complicates the
whole analysis because for one double
jeopardy doesn't attach so it's not like
there's something binding because the
prosecution was declined
but the part that gets complicated is
whether or not they declined to
prosecute based upon a real analysis of
the evidence or whether this was a rogue
prosecutor acting in a personal way and
if that's the case then the da's office
can distance themselves from that
decision and have another shot at him so
i think it's gonna be interesting to see
how this plays out and of course it's
going to mirror what happens to the
criminal prosecution yeah we'll see how
the defense brings up this issue i'm
sure the prosecution will dive right
into it in the case of the death for a
mod arbory when we come back the uns of
disappearance of kathy durst now
includes a link from the first lady's
past could joe biden's ex-husband be the
missing piece in the unsolved case hear
bill stevenson's side of the story after
this
[Music]
welcome back real estate air robert
durst is sentenced after he's found
guilty for murder
durst's guilty verdict came last month
after the lengthy trial for the 2000
murder of the durst's best friend susan
berman prosecutors say his motive was
that berman had information about his
missing wife kathy they allege he
murdered kathy in new york back in 1982
and that berman was going to come
forward with information on that case
more than 40 years after kathy durst's
disappearance her body was not been
found she was legally declared dead in
2017. durham spent three weeks on the
stand testifying in his own defense
after just three days and only seven and
a half hours the jury reached a guilty
verdict of murder with the special
circumstances of killing a potential
witness and lying in wait sentencing was
set for thursday
as dirt sentencing for the murder of
susan berman is doled out the 78 year
old could face even more charges out of
new york in connection to the
disappearance and death of his wife
kathy mccormick durst the westchester
county da's office is reportedly
convening a grand jury and prosecutors
already named a star witness
bill stevenson the ex-husband of first
lady joe biden claims to have a long
history with kathy mccormick durst
stevenson says the two had been lifelong
friends before things turned romantic he
says the two were having an affair the
same year that she disappeared in an
exclusive interview with news 12
westchester stephenson says he witnessed
robert durst make violent threats
towards kathy durst he says she
disappeared just one week later as news
12 westchester reports stevenson was
approached by new york state
investigators about the relationship
the next thing i realize
we hear pounding on the door it's like 7
30 in the morning she runs out of the
bedroom
and
she runs back in and she says it's it's
bob i jumped up i ran out and then all
of a sudden he screams something but he
goes like this he had a lot of like cash
rolled up and hit her right in the face
with it
katie this sentencing has been a long
time coming how long do you expect durst
to be sentenced and do you think his age
or health will help reduce that number
you know brian durst has had a lot of
lucky breaks over time he's gotten very
lenient sentences in previous instances
and i don't think that that's going to
happen here he has tried at every turn
to really lessen the blow of the severe
finding and i don't think it's going to
happen now especially with the looming
threats he has so i project that the
judge is going to throw the book at him
i can see that as well terry how do you
see the new developments in the murder
for kathy durst playing out could we see
an indictment in that soon
you know we really could see an
indictment in westchester county in new
york here i think the fact that they
have convened a grand jury they have
this new star witness bill stevenson who
is talking about the fact that he saw
durst and durst was violent as it
related to kathy and he said he had an
affair so he was very close with kathy
durst and i think that if he is to
testify in front of that grand jury we
could have an indictment and we really
could see durst potentially having
another trial i think though i agree
with katie i think he is going to
probably get a sentence of
you know life without parole so the real
question is uh you know is he going to
get that sentence in california now
terry did i hear you right that you
think that kathy that robert durst may
potentially have another trial i'm not
disagreeing that he gets indicted my
question is do you think he'll live long
enough to see a second trial
you know it's interesting we saw him
during the trial and how he gradually
got weaker and weaker he had you know a
bag that he had to carry with him he had
to at one point go to the hospital and
he couldn't come to the courtroom so we
know he has multiple illnesses so many
that he had to list them off and he
actually joked about did he include
everything so there's a real possibility
that he won't live long enough to face
another trial in westchester county yeah
maybe john lewin will wave into new york
to prosecute the case as well but we'll
see
thank you for joining us here at law and
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you